hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast stream the line clinical
trials
applying rigor in flow centometry
to facilitate therapeutic developments
presented by
dr elena lelich the field marketing
manager
for flow cytometry at beckmann culture
life sciences
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by beckmann
coulter life sciences
for more information on our sponsor
please visit them at www.beckman.com
now let's get started i'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during that
presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click the send button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right
of your presentation window or report
your problem
by clicking on the ask a box located on
the far
left of your screen this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits without further ado
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr alina
lelich for a complete biography on our
speaker
please visit the biography tab on the
top of your screen
dr lilich you may now begin your
presentation
welcome thanks susie and thank you
everybody for attending this webinar
that's going to discuss streamline
clinical trials and specifically
how we can apply rigor to flow cytometry
to facilitate therapeutic development
the purpose of this presentation and and
the education itself is really to
provide you insight information and
hopefully some
um really good practical solutions
in terms of your own slow psychometric
workflows
that are going to progress your
scientific endeavors and
progress your scientific excellence so
we're going to begin so how exactly does
science translate
to medicine many of us who are stuck in
the lab
and we're doing the science at our lab
bench we forget the final outcome and
the purpose of why we're doing the
science
but ultimately it's to progress the
science into medicine and
today catching up to coronavirus which
is
quite an interesting time that we live
in this pandemic we can see this report
that's
that shows 60 treatments that are
currently in development
so these treatments obviously came from
the pre-clinical trials that were
developed in labs in animal models
but if we just simply look at the
clinicaltrials.gov
what we're going to notice is that what
we're going to note is that
there are um today 997
covid related clinical trials of those
695
are evaluating therapies so what this
shows us
is that clinical trials are extremely
important in terms of
developing developing the actual
methodologies
and evaluating the therapies that are
in clinical trials so how do we relate
flow cytometry click on trial
so in the same token if we just simply
go to
clinicaltrials.gov what we'll note is
uh just if you search into the study tr
uh study title for cytometry what you'll
note is
629 clinical trials that are focused
around flow
this is definitely an underestimated
number because of the fact that i'm
looking for the title
in the actual search criteria and
there's definitely a large number of
trials that are involved
in utilizing faucetometry as a method so
collectively
clinical trial evaluates the medicine
and flow cytometry is the method by
which we can
actually do this so how precisely can we
utilize with cytometry and biomedical
research
well closeotometry allows us to
characterize and evaluate
single cells and specifically how these
uh how the how the therapies that we're
evaluating
modulate the effects on the immune
system
so if we're looking at specific
therapies in mind
we're going to analyze and assess cells
based on their phenotype function health
as well as the viability
and in terms of activation and
differentiation of these uh
therapies how they how they translate uh
specifically
on a cell that cell-based levels to
identify potential biomarkers
in longitudinal studies and a
comprehensive analysis of the immune
system
and we do so after the administration of
therapies that are being evaluated such
as
prophylactic vaccines drugs in drugs
that we're looking at or
smaller large molecules so collectively
we have the capacity to characterize the
immune response
and potentially identify these
biomarkers that are going to
either allow us to address disease
disease progression or disease hulk so
correlate
but what's important to understand is
that flow cytometry is in fact a
quasi-quantitative and a qualitative
assay
so it's going to give us numeric and
categoric data
which is actually correlated data so
this correlated data
in essence lacks the the method itself
lacks calibration standards
we don't have the proportionality to the
amount of analyte
and because of this it is very important
that we validate the method for
imprecision
what that means is that we need to
understand the error
in terms of the excuse me the error of
measurement that we are
obtaining um and the reason for this is
because
how do we ensure that this
quasi-quantitative
and the qualitative assays are
reproducible because that's essentially
what we need to obtain
in order to analyze the therapies that
are in clinical trials
so scientific rigor is one aspect
by which we can obtain reproducibility
but before we delve into scientific
rigor let's specifically define it in
the context that we're
discussing here so the rigor is a strict
application of our scientific methods
what that means is we're going to ensure
that our experimental design
methodology analysis interpretation and
reporting
is unbiased and well controlled so that
it can be reproduced by
each scientist irrespective you know
when they do it
so scientific rigor ultimately is going
to lead reproducible data
for translational purposes that we just
discussed of science science to medicine
which is going to in turn allows
development immune of immune modulating
therapies
to treat the patient when it's necessary
so understanding that we have scientific
rigor it's something that's been applied
in science
for as long as we've been studying it
and considering the fact that the nih
has actually put
together a rigor and reproducibility
grant
that scientists can apply for why are we
discussing this
if we understand it there if we know
that it can be utilized
why are we talking about rigor could it
be because there is a reproducibility
crisis in science
and unfortunately that is the case if we
look at the preclinical data that's been
generated in the united states
and i'm not showing you costs here but
fifty percent of the data
that is reported is irreproducible
and this uh wages on various components
of reproducibility which are listed in
this
schematic here which you can see are
reagents and materials
study design data analysis reporting and
protocols
all within the control of the scientists
themselves so why
is it that these materials and reagents
that we can actually control and ensure
that we
are rigorously implementing into our
experiments
are producing such a a massive and
alarming number of reproducible studies
and ultimately the irreproducibility
leads to delays in therapeutic
development
and increased costs and this is
something that obviously
is unacceptable and needs to be changed
so the reproducibility issues especially
in the bioanalysis such as for cytometry
has been addressed in a workshop uh an
annual workshop that occurs
um it's called the workshop on recent
issues in bioanalysis
where global leading global biopharma
cross biotech companies as well as
regulatory agencies come together
and they discuss issues and they
develop guidelines and specific
information
that could be utilized and disseminated
across the scientific community
to implement some sort of rigor so that
we could develop better studies
and expedite the development
of but accurately expedited developments
of
therapy and last year the guidelines for
force of the metric bioanalysis
came up with several points that i'm
going to address here
the first one was the use of asr
reagents asr reagents also known as
analyte specific reagents
so when it comes to flow cytometry these
reagents will be monoclonal or polyconal
antibodies that are gmp manufactured
and they're analyte specific because of
the fact that they've been evaluated for
their specificity
they're manufactured in the gmp facility
and they have qualification
uh that comes with the actual product
itself
that bear that shows you the um utility
specific certificate of analysis and
eliminates you
from having to do an in-house evaluation
of the product itself
the next aspect of when utilizing flow
cytometry reagents is to ensure that you
determine the concentration
specificity clonality fluorescence of
protein ratio
uh and immunogen information so when we
are dealing with gmp
manufactured reagents such as asr
reagents
this is something that the vendor will
provide for you
and it's very useful because again it
eliminates the need for you to do so
however if this information if you are
using rule reagents
it's critical that you actually have a
validation and a specification for your
reagents when you're doing
prior to you starting your clinical
trial
titration of antibodies this is
something that we hear all the time
it is a critical aspect in flow
cytometry because it can definitely
produce erroneous data so ensure that
when you do
have law changes of your antibodies
antibodies ensure that
during the duration of your study
that you're titrating the antibodies
appropriately and that you record these
titrations
inclusion of fmls for dating this isn't
an issue when we have beautifully
separated populations distinct
populations where you can
discern positive from a negative but
especially in the case we're using
uh where we have cellular therapies
where the um
antigen of interest is a
has a modular effect and we can't
necessarily discern a positive for a
negative
it's important to include those fmos so
that we can utilize them for gating
but not just for gaining but also for
compensation
matrix validation
next it's important to validate and
ensure that if you have
changed any of the reagents or if
anything has
any changes have occurred during the
duration of your clinical trial
that you validate this um that also
means that
if reagent lots are changed you're going
to ensure that these reagent
lots are validated and that you've cross
checked them against the previous lot
and lastly when you're reading an mfi
such as in the case of activation
markers cd69 or whatever it is that
you're looking at
ensure that you're normalizing your
actual instruments with
mesf beats so that you can accurately
report out the mfi
so now that we've discussed the fact
that there is rigor
and we have the scientific uh method
that backs it up and we've also
discussed the fact that
the scientific community discusses uh
guidelines and workflows
we're going to show you how to implement
streamline workflows
into your own cenometric assays and this
is quite simple
because based on the charts that i
previously showed you you can see the
component
of irreproducibility to the um
to the actual global problem of you know
reproduce
reproducibility and so what we're going
to break down the streamlined workflows
into is three aspects
the first one is going to be sample
preparation
so the important aspect of sample
preparation that we're going to hone
into
is limiting reagent variability next
aspect is minimizing or automating
pipetting
and lastly or if possible automate the
sample preparation itself
so collectively by sample preparation
we're going to introduce a streamlined
workflow that's going to be reproducible
the second aspect is data acquisition
this comes to
your instrumentation what kind of
instrument what kind of full cytometer
are you using have you calibrated and
evaluated your instrument performance
and stability
and have you standardized your
instrument setting during their
longitudinal study that you're
evaluating and lastly is the data
analysis
a lot of inconsistencies come from
manual gaiting so what we're going to
try to do
is highlight ways that you can actually
limit these inconsistencies
and utilize unbiased platforms to
analyze your data
so that you can reproduce it and not
have to delay
so the reagents when we talk about the
reagent
for the clinical trials and experiments
that we're looking at
we've discussed the fact that asr
specifications are going to give us
qualifications and qc report out so
ultimately what we want to do is limit
the validation that is needed in-house
because that takes time that takes
effort and that can
introduce additional errors so what
we're going to do
is we're going to leave that to the
vendor we're going to obtain unique
reagent identifiers from the vendors and
they can
these could be anything such as asr
specifications certificate of analysis
that come
with reagents gmp or iso specifications
so some reagents maybe i so specified
they have their own pre-qualified qc
procedures but they're not if they're
not necessarily gnp
so these are all very useful uh
specifications
and unique identifiers that you can
actually obtain from the vendor
next we're going to minimize reagent
lock changes
and actually we're going to minimize
changing any reagents during the
duration of the study
so prior to you developing your panel
design
make sure you validate and and evaluate
the
the panel so that you can lock it in and
ask the vendor
to lock in the law now obviously and
most likely you
you won't be able to lock the lock for
the duration of the entire study so
let's say three to five years
but what you want to do is limit the
number of lock changes
and this can be easily done the next
aspect that we need to ensure is that
the reagent stability
is evaluated again this can come from
the vendor itself
and a lot of the reagents that comes
with specifications will have an expiry
date so that takes so takes away from
you having to do it in-house
alternatively you'll have to check for
stability what that means
is check for the expiry check that the
fluorescence
uh has been diminished over time and
checking to ensure
that while you're actually you know
cocktailing your antibodies
the you you're not decreasing the actual
fluorescence and that's not causing a
degradation of your tandem
and lastly and most importantly we're
always going to
incorporate experimental control within
our daily workflows
this experimental control is the qc to
our entire workflow much like the qc of
the instrument
and the qc of the reagent that comes
with specifications
so we're going to discuss this in a
little more detail
now i just want to show you for
illustrative purposes the reagent
documentation that come with some of
these
asr reagents specifically so they'll
come with their own pre-qualified
specifications and these specifications
will show you the clonality
as well as protein fluorescence protein
ratios
and in terms of the certificate of
analysis you'll get the expiry date as
well as the batch record verification
which
tells you that the reagent itself
conforms to the qc specification
in addition oh i apologize for that
in addition you'll get a certificate of
analysis that is a little more detailed
that's going to show you
specifically what results are being
passed so that you can understand
the type of qc that's involved in your
reagent
now if we discuss incorporation or
experimental control
most of you will say well some of you
will know what it is but
uh what exactly is an experimental
control
so what this is it's an internally
qualified sample
that contains your antigens of interest
so what i mean by that
is let's say you're reporting out your
cd3 cd8 like your substance
ratios or your subset percentages what
you're going to do
is you're going to acquire a
leukopheresis product
and you're going to freeze it down into
aliquots and every time you run your
experiment
your internal control that you've
already validated
is going to be incorporated into that
experiment and when i say validate it
what i mean by that
is that the the actual product or
ubiquiforesis
sample is going to be run 20 times
uh individually prior to you setting it
up into the experiment
such that you can assess the ranges of
percentages of interest for your antigen
of interest
and the actual ranges that are
acceptable
so what we're going to do is we're going
to basically
generate an assay sheet that is
acceptable for your own
experimental qc now there are
manufacturing standards that are
available for purchase and we all know
that they exist
cytotroll and neutral and various other
cell types that are either
cryopreserved that are either preserved
utilizing specific
uh chemicals or lyophilized so you can
use these for your daily verification of
agents
and ultimately you always want to
include in experimental controls
because not only is it going to give you
the qc of your experiment
but it's going to tell you whether your
instrument is stable
whether you've incurred any pipetting
errors when it comes to cocktailing your
antibodies
or if something is just gone wrong with
the experiment itself
so the schematics here shows you a side
of troll sample here
that comes with an expected values and
ranges that shows you the percent
positive so
let's let's look at the cd3 which is the
second uh
or third row from the from the top and
cd3 percentages are 78 plus
78 plus or minus 8. if we look at the
second plot
flow plot you can see that the cd3
percentage here is 73
within the acceptable range so once you
run this sample within your
experiment that you are running on a
daily during your longitudinal study
you're basically just going to set it as
a path and incorporate this into the qc
of your experiment
quite simple now we discussed the fact
that we can introduce error into our
[ __ ] feeling
and we discussed the fact that this is
why this is another reason why we're
going to have an
internal control or an experimental
control so the liquid cocktail antibody
looks like this
we first design our panel we select the
antibody clones we select the dye
combination based on the antigen level
based on the fluorescent intensity
and we evaluate and verify the panel
performance
there's going to be several iterations
of the verification of your panel
performance because that takes some time
and the more the more fluorescence
or the more antigens we want to analyze
the more
uh laborious this process becomes but
ultimately once we verify the panel
performance we're going to
uh we're going to say that it's okay
we're going to optimize the preparation
protocol which
comes in hand with the sample
preparation and everything that entails
intact into that methodology
and we're going to create an sop for
cocktailing mixing as well as the qc
once this is all done the the assay
itself is transferred into the lab
so ultimately there's several
checkpoints where we can actually
introduce errors cocktailing errors
panel design errors
um even in the case of you know creating
an sop and and
making the cocktails that there's
several ways that we can introduce the
error
so if we look at the reagent variability
within the workflows
you all know that stating patterns in
intensity really depend on perpetting
accuracy and reagent shelf stability
so if a tandem die degrades you're going
to get
a diminished signal that you're not
necessarily going to know that it's
related to your reagent you may think
it's a biologically relevant
aspect but it's not so it's important to
understand that
antibody titrations cocktailing and
antibody validation themselves
are critical aspects of making sure that
your workflows are rigorous
but they do introduce risk of
variability and error if you have to
consistently do them
not only do they increase the error but
they also lead to loss of time
and loss of money which is something
that obviously we want to
make efficient so the question begs
do we have an alternative method to this
laborious workflow
that is currently available and it turns
out that there are
there are various vendors out there that
have optimized uh
the cocktail workflows by introducing
dry
and optimized ready-to-use cocktails and
so these cocktails are
basically dried down antibody panels
that have been pre-designed by experts
in the field that have been validated
and qc checked for you
and so they eliminate that entire
section of panel design
and the only aspect of that you need to
so first and foremost they're
dried so there's no cocktailing so the
error of
pipetting goes out of hand or you're
limiting the error of pipetting because
you still have to introduce the sample
into the tube
and so what you do by utilizing these
pre-designed app
panels and drive panels you're going to
verify the panel performance
test a lot and transfer the assay into
the lab
if it checks in that it's great
so ultimately what we're trying to do by
utilizing
these dry and optimized cocktails is
really
increase the efficiency of our workflows
so that we could
in fact progress the therapeutic
development
and ultimately what we want to do is
ensure that these panels
allow us the reproducibility that we
were lacking before
due to the introduction of errors into
the workflow
so ultimately beckman culture does have
these panels
and i just wanted to highlight the fact
that these panels were actually
something that the key expert opinions
that were
involved in the one study this is a
transplant this is a transplant
experiment that was done across the
globe came
to the actual scientists and said we
need stabilized panels
because reagent consistency and
reliability is
is something that is questionable so how
can we introduce these panels that we
can ship to
uh you know europe north america and
ensure
that the law that there's no pipetting
error so that that what we're looking at
is
truly biological irrelevance so
the scientists the beckman culture got
together with these key expert opinions
and they developed eight uh immune
phenotyping panels that are listed here
and basically this collaborative effort
led to a
beautiful design of these a panels that
can characterize the entire
phenotype of the immune system
technically and what i wanted to show
you here
is a couple of examples of these tubes
now it's important also to qualify that
a lot of these
panels are going to be are going to bear
their own quality standards
this one specifically is under a
specific iso manufacturing standard
which says that it comes which which
states that it comes with its own qc
specification
now if we look at the actual fluorescent
uh if we look at the panels here
for the int t-reg two what you'll find
is
eight antibody conjugates that define
and
differentiate your t-reg populations
based on flux v3 cd-39
and helios what's important to note is
that there are eight antibodies but
based on the configuration of your own
cytometer
you can actually add additional
antibodies if you want to characterize
your
t rags further so let's say you wanted
to look at
the memory marker you can introduce the
e45 ra are
all c4 is already in there but you can
introduce ccr7
and additional markers that definitely
can be
dropped into the panel with respect to
the iron granulocyte tube
we're looking at the phenotype of your
granulocytes based on cd15s in nc
cd16 but additionally you have the
capacity to do
additional drop-in antibodies if you
want to take the characterization
further
now the last tube that i'm showing you
here is the i am count tube
and this tube is extremely useful for
individuals that are doing drug
discovery because all it contains is the
cd45 counting bead 7ad
and you can easily drop a pi into the
actual mix
and look at the proportion of your
healthy cells based on apoptosis
necrosis
and various other markers really now in
addition to
the phenotyping panels function
functional characterization of the
immune system is of great importance and
when you are
looking at clinical trials evaluating
the functionality of your cells is
something that is also critical
these panels again provide robust
cocktails
that can be uh reproducibly used across
multi-sites and so utilizing them and
taking out the you know pipetting errors
of cocktailing and so on
you can you you can look at the
activation of t cells t helper cells
monocytes and basophils
and ultimately showing you here a sample
that differentiates
that differentiates the functionality of
your cd4 t
cells based on il-4 gamma and il-2 and
il-17
so ultimately you can still see that
there are various drop-ins available
here
so if these markers are not enough and
if you want to look at additional
activation markers of your t-cells
you can do so by dropping them in so the
panel
panel itself serves as a base
or serves as the backbone that can then
have additional antibodies
for further characterization and lastly
if for any individuals who are doing
clinical trials
or and to detect rare events
there are several panels that are
available commercially available
and these can assess cll
multiple myeloma as well as all and they
contain various markers here that i
identified so based on the alb tube
in the case of clinical trials for all
we're looking at rare events that are
cd10 positive and
you can see the speckles of those rare
events that have been obviously
emphasized by the large dots but you can
see the differentiation of the rare
events in comparison to the normal
so collectively these panels have been
validated
and have been they bear a quality
standard with them
but ultimately they allow individuals
who are doing multi-site clinical trials
to really implement rigor into their
workflows
and in addition to that their reagents
they reduce reagent variability
their stability tested antibody panels
so if we compare them to the liquid
reagents
you can clearly see that the comparison
between them is
on par the brightness is preserved
there's no changes in compensation
so the ease of use does not come
at the actual um expense of
you know losing the brightness so this
is extremely important
in addition to that these panels for
most vendors are room temperature stable
which is wonderful because they don't
require a refrigeration
so they're also stable at extreme
temperatures
and this is just to show that you know
utilizing these panels
is really a great utility for let's say
that you're shipping them across the
world and if something happens all you
need to do is
validate it with a different sample set
that you have
and ensure that the panel still contains
the the same brightness across all dies
so what this goes to show is that there
are workflows that you can implement
into your own
laboratory and into your own clinical
trials that are going to for sure
reduce the error that's associated with
reagent workflows reagent errors
so in essence we can still reduce
experimental variability
by utilizing automated workflows and
this comes so what i'm showing you here
is a figure of an integrated automation
handler
with a flow cytometer and so what this
is going to this automated workflow is
going to basically prepare the sample
for you
cocktail the antibodies introduce the
antivir
introduce the staining of the antibodies
spin the antibodies
utilizing the centrifuge that's on deck
and
and then ultimately take the sample that
is stained into the flow cytometer
and then if you have integrated it into
the lis system
you can actually uh you can actually
export your samples for the analysis
so this integrated workflow is a is a
really
the comprehensive solution of uh
streamlined workflows and i'm just going
to show you a video here
that highlights how specifically it
works
in this in this particular configuration
okay so now that we've seen how the
automation works
we're going to discuss what kind of
sample
output do we get from it so in this
particular case
uh we wanted to reduce the experimental
variability utilizing the automated
workflows and we did so by
analyzing 96 uh well precisely what you
saw in the video there
to assess the phenotype of t cells and
really evaluate the intra acid
reproducibility
so what you see on the left hand axis is
the
mean of the phenotype in terms of the
percentages of the cells that are
described on the bottom axis
and what you see on the right hand side
is the percent cv
so collectively the analysis of the
t-cell phenotype showed less than 20
variability among the 96 well replicas
and that's actually quite
great especially when it comes to the
fact that even in the cases where the
percentages
of the positive populations were 2 or
less where the variability is going to
be
the most based on the fact that it's the
lowest
numbers so what we get here is
really the capacity to reproduce our
intra assay
and ensure that our sample workflows are
indeed reproducible
so now that we've talked about um
now that we've talked about the reagent
rigor
and how we introduce reproducibility
with our reagent workflow
we're going to actually move on to the
data acquisition and data acquisition
is going to discuss the instrumentation
so
flow cytometers are inherently different
we know this based on the optics fluidic
detectors and electronics
and ultimately today you have the
capacity to
choose any flow cytometer and if you do
so
the most important aspect is that every
instrument is evaluated and qualified
prior to your use
ensure that the iqoq has been provided
by the vendor
and that the instrument has been
validated in terms of the
the functionality but then in addition
to the iqoq
it's critical that you evaluate your
instrument based on quantum efficiency
electronic and optical background
as well as the spillover matrix why
because this is going to allow you to
this is going to allow you to see the
best resolution of your signal
and to ensure that the signal that
you're detecting isn't noise
but it's actual true uh value and why
again
is also to introduce the this
reproducibility that we're going to
discuss
uh in terms of the data and now
acquisition
now also understanding spillover
spreading matrix if you are generating
your own panels
you need you need to understand the
detectors and how different
the spectral overlap of the different
detectors so this is something that you
will definitely need to evaluate
if you are designing your own panel in
addition to that
it is important that if you are doing
clinical trials
and you're going to be reporting your
data to the fda
utilize this 21 cfr part 11 compliance
tool
these are the sda mandated tools that
basically state that electronic records
and signatures are consistent
are considered trustworthy reliable and
can be
relevant to equivalent to the paper
records that you have
so many instruments do have the cfr 511
compliance tools
utilize them accordingly and make sure
that you sign off
and that all the data is tracked in
addition to
what we talked about in in terms of
calibrating your instrument
it's important to optimize your
instrument settings what does this mean
it means that you inspect and you
understand the entire dynamic range of
your instrument
you can easily do so by simply running
your ap beads
and understanding the resolution of the
fluorescent signal
now you know that it depends on
instrument sensitivity and the overall
performance
so what that tells you technically is
where exactly your
instrument sensitivity is and how far
you can push your analysis
where you can place the you know which
channels you can place your dim markers
on and how you can analyze your
samples the best the additional aspect
of instrument
instrument setting optimization is going
to enable at best resolution
and ultimately consistent data
acquisition but then translate
into the next aspect which is the
standardization of instrument settings
this is very critical if we are looking
at longitudinal studies it is critical
that we standardize the optimized
settings that we've evaluated
utilizing a bead particle what this
means is that we're going to use the
same standardized setting for the
duration of the clinical study
and the purpose of this is to with with
assurance
state that biological
biological differences that we're seeing
uh from a sample from day 0 to day 30 or
a year out is actually due to the
biological difference and not the
setting
shifts so what we do is we utilize an
actual bead particle and we
set the target channels so that these
target channels are acquired on a daily
the standardization as well as the qc
protocol much as the inclusion of the
experi
experimental control must be done on the
daily and they must be tracked
so the reason for this is because the
standardized
instrument settings enable reproducible
data acquisition
and this again is important for us
because we want to ensure robust
uh development of methods especially
when it comes to full cytometry so
that we can progress the therapeutic
developments and bring them into
medicine
now it isn't enough to just optimize
your setting and to standardize them
it is critical that you verify that
these settings are actually accurate
and not just the settings but the
compensation matrix but
so what i'm going to show you here is
just a simple subset
panel that was done on pvmcs and what
you're looking at here
is the live data discriminator in the
zombie red channel and cd3
and then gating on cd8 and cd4 so what
you see here
is in the first sample 99
of your actual pbmcs are cv3 positive
so that comes a little bit of a lot this
comes as a bit of an alarm because most
of you will understand that
99 is a bit it's a bit
high so then you go on to validate and
if you look at your compensation matrix
you can see that some of these values
are really high
and you may think to check based on your
fmos
the compensation matrix so after you
check your compensation matrix
and you adjust the compensation matrix
you realize
that the actual population of cd3
positive events is 79
and you realize that the compensation
error occurred due to the
over compensation of your zombie red
that spilled into your
bb605 channel so oops sorry about that
so what this says if you were reporting
out your cd3 values
you would basically report our erroneous
data and that would be a problem
because in the end uh unoptimized
acquisition setting and compensation
would actually
generate this erroneous data which
wasn't accurate
and if you were to try to reproduce this
again utilizing different settings that
were optimized
you would not get the same outcome so
this is definitely a problem
that we need to watch out for now lastly
we're going to discuss data analysis
which again
becomes extremely cumbersome because if
we look at if
as we increase the complexity of our
data analysis and increase the number of
parameters that we're actually
analyzing we realize that there is
challenges of high dimensionality data
and analysis and not just from analyzing
these few flow plots
but also as we increase that number it
becomes extremely difficult
to analyze that many plots and
ultimately there is a bias
that's associated but more so
variability in manual gating
you're not going to consistently
introduce the same gating methodology
from one sample to the next
and ultimately there's as i said user
bias in gating
what i consider a positive event you may
not
it's going to be easy when we have these
beautifully discerned positives and
negatives
but when there is a modular antigen in
hand
or in question things are going to
differ so how do we ensure
that we can actually reproduce data
analysis results
well and it becomes a challenge so what
if i told you
that we could actually reduce the number
of plots and eliminate the bias
and it's pretty much it's quite simple
there's algorithms that can do so
and so what if i told you that all of
these plots that you're seeing here
we can just simply convert into this
beautiful one
disney plot that separates our
populations based on these islands
and segregates them out based on uh
likelihood so if you look at all of
these events in these islands they
segregate out based on
events that are highly similar together
so the z value here is a cda
so based on the heat map here the island
that shows cd8 or where your cda t cells
lie
is right there so we've basically taken
out that complex analysis of multitude
of biplots and translated to a simple
one
that we can then further analyze and
segregate into meta clusters
and differentiate the expression of
several different markers
utilizing a flow some analysis algorithm
so
in essence unsupervised and supervised
machine learning algorithms that are
readily available
that rain that spans from spain citrus
vinsny flow sun these are just a few
that i'm outlining here
that literally have the capacity to
reduce the dimensionality like we saw
there
cluster identify differences between our
data sets so if we are comparing
one treatment to a different treatment
we can clearly
see differences that come without the
bias of gating that we initially saw
from the biplots or we could utilize
clustering map and identify
basically populations that of interest
that can then be
even further segregated down to
understand relative expression levels so
ultimately the
utility of unsupervised and supervised
machine learning algorithms
reduces the complexity of the data
without
actually losing the complexity of the
data
and but it eliminates the bias of the
manual getting which is extremely
important when we're doing the
variability
uh when we're dealing with variability
of clinical samples and any of you who
have dealt with clinical samples you'll
understand that there is a massive
variability from sample to sample
and then ultimately we objectively want
to discover new populations
whether these new populations lead to
biomarkers
or whether they give us prognosis
factors this is the ultimate goal
so that we could understand how the
therapeutic development
is actually progressing but ultimately
what we need to do
is apply the rigor in reagent
analysis as well as acquisition to
ensure that this is the case
so ultimately how what is the
significance of rigor in clinical
research
it is to implement efficient technical
transfer whenever we're dealing with
multi-site clinical trials
longitudinal analysis and so this is
important so that we streamline
uh and develop streamlined workloads to
reduce error
and reduce variability so that we can
repeat these assay
and ensure that what we've reported in
the pre-clinical study
is as accurate as what we're what we're
reporting in phase
you know one through uh whatever
what we want to do ultimately is reduce
the experimental costs
these these trials cost a lot of money
and we want to reduce this cost so that
we can expedite the process
the the rigor in clinical trial is going
to allow us to generate efficient and
reproducible workflows
and the ultimate goal is to utilize
unbiased evaluation of therapies and
clinical trials so that we can progress
these therapies into medicine
so in the end reproducibility through
rigorous scientific method
validates what we've seen previously in
our clinical in our pre-clinical data
and allows for progression and the
development immune therapies that are
extremely important
to the human kind so i'm just giving you
a few resources here
that if any of you are interested you
can click on these links here
or ask the questions but ultimately i
want to thank you for your time
and i hope that you have lots of
questions for me
thank you
thank you dr levilich for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now simply click on the ask
a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
coming in dr loch is if you do not have
access to an internal control cell
is it appropriate to use beads
um okay so we're talking about an
internal control
no and the reason i mean your beat
you're going to use
for your standardized experiments but
what you want to do
is um ultimately utilize the actual in
a biological sample that you're going to
gate
utilizing a specific gating strategy so
that you can see the progression of the
gating and so that you can see if
there's any drifts or shifts in the
fluorescence intensity
so beads might shift slightly but you
won't be able to see
that actual biological relevance onto
the population
so an internal sample itself
the bead itself is going to be utilized
for your qc of the sample
but with respect to utilizing it as an
internal control as a
experimental control it isn't sufficient
unfortunately
and does the variation come from
antibody design
or probe conjunction and is there a
choice of the probe
uh a choice of the probe um if you don't
mind just
elaborating on that but yes the
variation can definitely come from
antibody
uh and i'm assuming you're asking about
the panel design
um so the panel design definitely can
have some variability this is why we're
going to include our fmo
and we're going to test the antibody
panel with
single so let's say we're defining
designing a panel
what you're going to do is you're going
to include just
a minimum number of
of antibody conjugates to understand
the actual true percentage of the
population of interest
and then you're going to start
introducing additional antibodies into
that
once you start taking out your
fluorescence minus one
you're going to see if the actual
introduction of new antibody conjugates
is going to play an effect on the actual
uh
percentages that you're reading out so
this would be the
accurate way of designing your actual
panel and validating it
thank you for that and i want to thank
our audience again for the great
questions
coming in and remind you that any
questions that are not answered today
will be answered
via email our next question also has to
do with design
when designing and planning a project
with dried down
custom designed multi-color panels would
you suggest
testing the panel with a wet anti-body
cocktail
to ensure the performance is correct
you can but ultimately what you're going
to do
is you're going to reach out to the
vendor and they have their own
application scientists who
understand their reagents understand the
uh the clones and they have the capacity
to design these panels for you
so what you can do is work with the
application scientists
who will ensure that these panels are
probably
that are going to be that are going to
give you the best emission spectrum
however excuse me if you do want to
evaluate
let's say uh you know this is a brand
new panel that you're analyzing and
you've designed it together
we're most likely going to test it
in-house we're going to the the
manufacturer is going to test to ensure
that you're getting
and they'll give you the antibodies most
likely to test to see
if the percentages of the of the report
outs
are accurate and so such that the panel
that you're designing together
gives you the best readout
thank you for that our next audience
member says great presentation
thank you so much and for the dried down
anti-body
multi-color panels can you add an
appropriate fixable live
dead marker and his second part of the
question is
can you add in bz bu v
or bb conjunct um conj
conjugated antibodies to the panel
uh-huh so at the moment uh beckman
coulter
does not have we cannot drive down
brilliant dyes
surgeon dies and the reason for that is
they are
extremely sticky so what happens is when
you add them when you dry them down
they lose the actual intensity because
they stick together
so we don't have the capacity i don't
know with
other manufacturers but based on the
actual chemical
compositions of the dyes i'm tempted to
say that this would be
not an easy process so the bbs are
not easy to dry down but it's being
worked on
and the second question uh the first
question sorry
that was do you remind repeat do you
mind repeating it again sorry
surely sure no problem it says um
uh given oh i'm sorry i think i've
i've lost that part um
hold on one second i apologize
on my phone i
i apologize um i don't think i can
repeat that part let me see if we can
bring that back up
and um while we're doing that let me ask
ask you the next question
thank you sorry nothing no worries
given the option would you recommend
slacking as
as many i'm sorry stacking as many
antibodies as possible
in one tube or splitting it into
multiple
tubes and for the second approach how
would you combine
population frequencies reported in
different tubes given that there
is not a universal parent
okay so if we are
stacking antibodies can definitely be
applied to your panel i
if if you're doing algorithms if you're
going to analyze your data utilizing
algorithms
i uh there's going to be a little more
manipulation in terms of the manual
gating that you'll have to do
to begin with so me personally
i prefer to separate my tubes and then
look at the analysis rather than
stacking them
but ultimately you can stack and do some
pre-qualification of the actual data so
manual gating and then importing those
specific gates to look at the analysis
of the populations of interest
now in terms of how do you amalgamate
the data
if you are using you can merge data
from different tubes now i know that
kalooza analysis allows you to do this
and so basically by merging the data
sets
if it's the same tube it would have to
be the same panel unfortunately so
you can do this in in the algorithm so
there is a capacity
by which if it's the same sample
obviously and you have different
sample sets there is a way that you can
actually merge the datasets and look
at the expression of the antigen
thank you for that and which software
would you advise
advise for complex data analysis
well that's a really good question but
it depends on what you're trying to
assess
so i mean the great thing about all of
these algorithms is you can layer them
so for example most individuals who are
doing
um conflict data analysis they're gonna
they're gonna start with visney and
they're gonna they usually layer flow
some onto it
but if you are working with let's say
patient samples
citrus is a really beautiful algorithm
that allows you
to look at you know biomarker
identification
and different treatment differences in
the treatment options and so on
so ultimately you have a various
platform of different
algorithms that you can utilize the best
thing to do
would be to actually reach out to the
actual data scientists
or the application scientists for the
different
software and ask them or alternatively
try the different ones and see what the
data gives you
thank you for that dr lilitz and thank
you again audience members for these
great questions coming in
our next question in discussing the dry
optimized antibody cocktails
are these the only options available in
terms of antibody
antigen combinations or can different
panels be designed
yeah so there these are just the ones
that are
uh available off the shelf but
um i'm sure that well i know beckman
culture for sure
has a custom design services where you
can sit down with an application
scientist and an expert
and design your own panel of choice and
evaluate that panel
and then transfer it to your own
laboratory
so they're not the only ones
thank you and what is better getting
control and fmo
or internal negative control
so uh if you have an internal negative
control that's
that's going to be the best choice for
your because then it precludes you from
wasting additional reagents on including
an fml
however so fmos can be used if you are
using pvmcs or whole blood because you
have a slew of populations that are
not expressing your choice your you know
fluorescence
marker or your antigen of choice so you
have the capacity to do so
however for clinical trials
that are evaluating cellular therapies
that have been
that have undergone
that have basically gone through the
process of expansion
and you have one population of interest
or you have somewhat of a
homogeneous population in that
particular case fmos are the only option
you have
thank you for that and we have time for
a couple more questions
this next question is a two-part
question can you explain
how you're using tsne to bypass
compensation matrices and it was not
clear to me how
you use uncommon uncompensated data
to segregate populations how can you
differentiate
true signals from noise
uh so you should never use uncompensated
data
um and i'm i'm really sorry that i
if that was lost in in my message it
wasn't what i was trying to say
so you should always compensate your
data and the data that i was showing you
in the in the slide in this slide here
this data was actually compensated um
are they able to see my slides or are
the slides gone i'm just curious
yes you can still see this slide okay
perfect
so the data example that i'm showing you
here this was actually compensated data
and how we evaluated that the
compensation itself was
inaccurate was by checking single
single thing controls with the cells and
evaluating to see
whether or not really the cd3 population
was accurate
once we established the uh the accurate
numbers we realized that there was
a an overcompensation and we manually
comp we manually change the compensation
however
for future analysis for this particular
experiment
uh this wasn't an experiment that i did
personally this was a sample set that
was given to me by one of our
colleagues so what i would do for the
future of this experiment
i would actually ensure that the
settings as well as the compensation
matrix are optimized by utilizing these
single cell controls to ensure that's
the case
and then there was a second part to the
question
yes the how how you use and well i think
that was the first
on the second part actually can you
explain how you're using
tsne to bypass compensation matrices
tsne uh oh disney i believe okay um
so tiffany never so you cannot utilize
tis me
to bypass compensation if you bring
in uncompensated data into your kisme it
will not work
so what you need to ensure is that prior
to bringing your data
into the algorithm and and importing it
onto the cytobank
platform you have to ensure that the
data has been qc'd
so what you'll do is you might use a
software like
palooza uh or flojo and you're going to
ensure that the compensation is accurate
by again looking at your single cell
controls and then
ensuring that the compensation is is
accounted for if not
then check for it adjust it manually
obviously but by using the
the single the fm modes and then export
your data into
uh cytobank for analysis by chisney
thank you for that and you showed
several dry cocktails that are available
by beckman coulter are these specific
for beckmann coulter's instrumentation
or can they be run or other flow
cytometers
uh no so they're not specific to beckman
culture
instrumentation the beautiful part about
these uh so these can be
run on any cytometer any commercially
available automata that
has the appropriate bandpass filter
obviously so
uh we provide you with the die and you
can see the emission of it in the ifu
for the product itself
and then you can basically run it on any
platform
thank you and dr lilitch can a lab use
the
internal control to evaluate getting
strategy
and applying the control gating strategy
to the clinical samples
uh so if the internal control
is a cri if the internal control
mimics what you have as your
sample as your clinical sample so let's
say it's a pbmc
you can kind of gauge it but i would
advise against it and the reason why is
because
we talked about i touched upon sample
variability
all samples are different so in terms of
you know looking
at separation of of antigens that are
you know very discrete sure but if you
are looking at modulating uh
effect uh you know modular expression of
markers
in that particular case your controls
are going to be needed
and those controls are either you know
your
your day zero treatment and versus your
day 30
or your fmo so those are going to be
needed
dr lovelich thank you for your
presentation today and do you have any
final comments for our audience members
before we close
uh stay healthy and stay safe and it's
been a real pleasure
if you guys have any questions please
reach out to us
i will be happy to assist you in making
your science
excellent that's the goal for for what
we're trying to do here
dr ellis thank you again for your
presentation and for your important
research and before we go
i want to thank audience members for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information
be provided at the time of our
registration we would like to thank
you again and we also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor
beckman coulter life sciences and lab
roots for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand
and labyrinths will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time bye-bye and
stay
healthy